Hey Torontonians, recycling is more than a routine. It's a vital responsibility. By recycling properly, you help conserve resources, reduce energy use in greenhouse gas emissions, and protect the environment. Toronto's Blue Bin Recycling Program ensures the majority of the right items are recovered and transformed into new products. Recycling right is important and impactful. Let's work together and make a difference, because small actions lead to big change. For more tips on recycling, visit toronto.ca slash recycle right.
Some stories are so profound, so unimaginable, that they stay with us forever. The Unthinkable is the latest podcast from Casefile Presents, hosted by two of Australia's leading voices in true crime, Vicky Petratus and Emily Webb. The series delves into tales of ordinary people who have faced extraordinary, often devastating events and emerged forever changed. From survivors of traumatic events, to victims of relentless stalking, and even those who've confronted some of Australia's most notorious criminals, The Unthinkable explores the depths of human resilience. The first two episodes feature the incredible story of Louisa Hope, a woman who survived Sydney's Lindt Cafe siege in 2014. Both episodes will be available for free on Sunday November 10 wherever you get your podcasts,
with episodes dropping weekly after that. Be sure to follow The Unthinkable so you don't miss an episode. Stay tuned until the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. 26-year-old Sean Stouty's Facebook page was an extension of himself. He once shared a post on the social media website that read,
I don't know how I would live if I was not on Facebook. Multiple times a day, Sean would post whatever random thoughts popped into his head, from asking if platypuses could be kept as pets to musing about celebrities. He quoted his favourite television shows and summarised recently viewed episodes of Malcolm in the Middle. He was also notably introspective, writing, "...starting next week, I'm going to act totally normal. Shaun had been diagnosed with autism, a developmental disorder that impaired his ability to communicate
and interact. He'd also suffered from seizures since birth, which prevented him from living independently. Attempts to house Shaun in an assisted living facility hadn't panned out, and he was unable to work due to being easily overwhelmed. As a young adult, Sean still lived at home with his parents and three younger sisters in the city of Springfield, Missouri. Sean's autism made it difficult for him to understand social cues and other people's behaviour. Although those who knew Sean thought he was nice and friendly, he could come across as impolite or insensitive to neurotypical strangers. He was aware of how his condition impacted others,
lamenting on his Facebook page, lamenting on his Facebook page, I'm not a bad person. I have social problems. All I want is to live a normal life. Every so often, Sean posted about his home life, anything from how his family's cars were getting their tyres pressure checked to venting about his dirty bedroom carpet. Then, in early April 2012, Sean's Facebook posts took on a new focus. He began sharing how his father, Mark Stouty, had started acting strangely. As Sean only had several online followers and they rarely engaged with his content, these posts drew little attention. Despite this, Sean continued to provide daily reports about his father's increasingly odd behaviour.
According to Sean, Mark Stouty was suffering mental problems that were also weakening his body. Quote, My father is slowly starting to have problems with the driving and accomplishing anything. When he drove a car, the car swerved a little bit. I had to help him keep the car direction straight and properly turning." In another post, he claimed his father was so insane that Sean didn't want to be friends with him anymore. On Saturday, April 7, Sean posted, My father is slowly getting sicker. His voice is slurred. His walking is wobbly. His body is more
tired than normal. He is sleeping in bed longer than us. He may collapse under his weight at any time." The next day, Sean wrote that his father had spent half the day in bed and was struggling with basic physical tasks. Then on Monday, April 9, Sean announced, My father died. He lived a full life. The cause of death is a stroke. His funeral is this week. His belongings now belong to my sisters. Sean Stouty wasn't the only one who had noticed Mark's declining health. Two days before Mark's death, he'd attended a recording session with his band, a blues outfit called Messing With Destiny. As the band's lead singer and guitarist, Mark had to project excitement and enthusiasm in order to put on a great show. This came naturally to Mark because music was his life's passion. It had even drawn him to his wife,
Diane, who was a church organist, and the couple endeavoured to pass their love of music down to their children. Messing with the Destiny was gradually gaining success, booking semi-regular gigs in neighbouring cities and making a small amount of money. So during their evening recording session on Friday April 6, Mark's bandmates were dismayed to see him uncharacteristically distracted, confused and slurring his words. They didn't think Mark was drunk, but wondered if his poor diet, lack of exercise or other unhealthy vices might have caught up with him. Mark also had bipolar disorder, a mental condition hallmarked by drastic mood swings
and manic episodes. Perhaps he was just going through a rough period. Mark stayed hydrated and went on several walks outside hoping to shake whatever ailed him. Despite losing his appetite, becoming increasingly lethargic and even vomiting, Mark didn't go to the doctor, nor did his family push him to seek medical treatment. It seemed like he just had a bad case of the flu, nothing that he wouldn't overcome in time. Saturday April 7 was Mark's 61st birthday and he went to a friend's house to celebrate. His friend was troubled by Mark's yellow complexion. Diane Stouty checked on her husband throughout the night but he was too fatigued to say much at all. By Sunday April 8, Mark was so sick that he couldn't go to church. His absence was surprising,
as the Stoutys were devout Christians and prominent members of their church community. The rest of the family went without Mark, who stayed behind to rest. Some time after they returned home, they found Mark in bed, unconscious and unresponsive. Diane called emergency services, but there was nothing they could do. Mark was dead. A ring of blood had dried around Mark's mouth. Other than that, he looked normal and had no signs of injury. Diane Stouty was able to detail her husband's final hours which culminated in him suffering three seizures on Sunday. He had never had a seizure before. The last one occurred 45 minutes before Diane found Mark not breathing. She said
she'd wanted to call 911 sooner but Mark had insisted that he didn't want to go to hospital. insisted that he didn't want to go to hospital. Diane explained that Mark had diabetes and was developing Alzheimer's which was gradually destroying his mental functions. This was in addition to liver problems he'd acquired from drinking alcohol in excess. Mark was also a long time cigarette smoker and would sometimes smoke cannabis. Upon observing Mark's body and taking his lifestyle and health into account, the county medical examiner concluded that the 61-year-old must have died of natural causes. They didn't think it was necessary to perform any tests or an autopsy. Diane Stouty announced Mark's untimely passing on her Facebook
page, telling the couple's devastated friends that her husband of 27 years had reached his eternal home. She quoted from the Gospel of John, "...let not your hearts be troubled. Believe in God. Believe also in me." Mark was cremated and his ashes scattered at a lake. The remaining members of Messing With Destiny performed a musical tribute for Mark at his memorial service and played his favourite song of theirs, titled Darkest Hour. Mark's daughter Rachel paid tribute to her father with a poem by influential German writer Johann Wolfgang von Goethe. Over the hilltops is calm. In all the treetops you feel hardly a breath of air.
The little birds fall silent in the woods. Just wait. Soon, you'll also be at rest." Mark's death was a huge blow to his family's dynamic. By all accounts, the Stouties were happy and full of love, support, and understanding. Mark was a devoted stay-at-home dad, as all of the Stoutie children were reliant on their parents in their own way. Eldest child and only son, Sean, lived with them on account of his health. 24-year-old Sarah, a university graduate who had accrued a large student loan debt, was struggling to find a job. 22-year-old Rachel was studying art history at college while pursuing her love of painting
and music. The Stouties' youngest child, an 11-year-old girl, Casevile, we'll refer to as Tia, had learning difficulties. Mark and Diane were very proud of their children. Diane referred to them as little professors, as each was an expert in their own special interests. 51-year-old Diane was the family breadwinner. She was a cardiology nurse who primarily worked from home assessing insurance company claims. At times, her income was not enough to support the family of six, so Mark took on odd jobs for extra cash.
Prior to Mark's passing, the Stouties lived in a small home in Springfield's suburban West. Their house needed a lot of work and the neighbourhood had some problems. Sean Stouty often vented about this on his Facebook page, going so far as to write, I need a better house to live in. His father's modest life insurance payout of $20,000 helped the family relocate to a larger house in a nicer area. Sean was delighted by the move. He posted about it online, writing, I am going to move out of a neighborhood of hell to a neighbourhood that has a low crime rate, has good people, has good schools, and has properly built houses."
In late April, Sean opened a new Facebook account in preparation for his fresh start. He continued posting near-daily whatever piqued his interest, but over the following months his online activity lessened. Sean acknowledged this on Saturday August 4, 2012, writing that he was sharing fewer posts than he had previously. Then he stopped posting altogether. Then he stopped posting altogether. By September 2012, five months after the unexpected death of Mark Stouty, his family had settled in to their new home. Then, on Sunday September 2, the Stouties arrived at their weekly church service with another notable absence. 26-year-old Sean was unable to attend as he was bedridden after suffering flu-like symptoms for
weeks. He could do little else but rest and stay hydrated in between long painful bouts of vomiting, head and muscle aches and appetite loss. When the Stouties returned home from church, they found Shaun unconscious on his bedroom floor. A ring of dried blood had formed around his mouth. Just like his father months earlier, Shaun had died unexpectedly after enduring a mysterious illness. On this occasion, the county medical examiner performed an autopsy. It revealed that Sean had a congenital kidney defect, signs of brain damage and a stroke, as well as damage to his central nervous system. Given Sean's history of seizures and other health issues, the medical examiner assumed that the young man had been struck down by a pre-existing condition.
Sean's death was officially ruled as being due to prior medical issues. The sudden deaths of Mark and Sean so close together left the local community reeling. Friends of the Stouties were shocked that a loving, pious family could have such awful luck. Two days after Sean's death, Diane Stouty posted a short tribute to her son on her Facebook page. It's been hard for me to come up with the right words, Diane wrote, but here goes. On Sunday, my oldest child, Sean, died. Although he had been sick lately, we thought he was getting better. Diane went on to thank those who had been keeping her family in their prayers, quote,
May we have a portion of the peace Sean now enjoys. Everyone was devastated for the now family of four who grew noticeably reclusive after Sean's death. His remains were cremated, but unlike his father, there was no funeral or memorial to honour his life. Diane Stouty seemed to be taking the loss of her husband and son in her stride. She focused on taking care of her three daughters, Sarah, Rachel and Tia, and threw herself into her music and church commitments. The local community rallied around Diane, who responded well to the guidance and support provided by her pastors. Even Diane's daughter, Rachel, was struck by how well her
mother coped in the aftermath of Sean's inexplicable death. Rachel posted on her Facebook page, don't think I've seen mum so chilled out like this in a long time. But this moment of calm was short lived. Nine months after the death of Shaun, the Stouty family was hit with more misfortune. 24-year-old Sarah Stouty had been found unconscious in bed after suffering severe flu-like symptoms. Diane bundled her eldest daughter into her car and rushed her to the hospital. her eldest daughter into her car and rushed her to the hospital. By the time Sarah arrived at the emergency department, her condition was so dire that she was swiftly admitted to the intensive care unit. Doctors soon discovered that Sarah wasn't just dealing with a nasty strain of the flu. Her kidneys had shut down, her pancreas was failing, and her brain was
hemorrhaging blood. Sarah had suffered a total body collapse. She'd had numerous strokes and seizures and most likely wouldn't survive. Multiple tests were performed but the cause of Sarah's illness remained a mystery. Diane Stouty took to Facebook to inform her friends of her family's latest tragedy. She wrote, asking for prayers as my daughter Sarah is in critical condition in the ICU tonight. She followed this up with an image that featured the biblical verse, "'Rejoice in our confident hope, be patient in trouble, and keep on praying.'" As news of Sarah Stouty's ordeal spread, Springfield police received a troubling phone call. The man on the other line said he wished to remain anonymous
but claimed to be a pastor at the Stouties' church. Upon hearing about Sarah's illness, he'd become overwhelmed with concern. Through his work, he had encountered many people who'd experienced considerable hardship and loss. However, he had never come across a family who had endured so much indiscriminate death in such a short time span as the Stouties. He brought up the close timing of Mark and Sean's deaths, which had been excused on account of their respective histories of poor health. But now the otherwise healthy Sarah was fighting for her life in a similar scenario.
The pastor had been counselling Diane Stouty and was struck by her lack of emotion in relation to it all. He had come to believe something was seriously amiss in the stouty home. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This episode is brought to you by IQ Bar. IQ Bar gives you the fuel and focus you need without the sugar crash. It's a filling, nutrient-rich option that keeps you energised all day. Casefile team member Andrew recently tried IQ Bar and loved the convenience and taste, especially the lemon blueberry flavour. He also appreciated the simple, healthy ingredients that provided ample protein
and fibre. To get you in the holiday spirit, IQ Bar has released some limited-time flavours, IQ Bar Gingerbread and IQ Joe Peppermint Mocker. While wellness can often take a backseat during the holidays, IQ Bar brings you festive treats that are actually good for you. Their protein-packed bars, mood-boosting hydration sticks and brain-boosting coffee will keep you full and focused. Their ultimate sampler pack includes all three products and right now IQ Bar is offering our podcast listeners an exclusive deal. 20% off all IQ Bar products plus get free shipping. With over 15,000 5-star reviews and counting, IQ Bar makes the number one brain and body nutrition bar, hydration mix,
and instant coffee in the US. Snack smarter with IQ Bar. There's more fibre, less sugar, and they're entirely free from gluten, dairy, and artificial sweeteners. And right now, IQ Bar is offering our special podcast listeners 20% off all IQ Bar products plus get free shipping. To get your 20% off, just text CASEFILE to 64000. Text CASEFILE to 64000.
That's CASEFILE to 64000. Message and data rates may apply. See terms for details. A lot has changed over the past year. Casefile has expanded its team, launched a new Casefile Presents series and even started hosting public events with Me On Stage. If you have a growing e-commerce business, you can relate. Whether you're looking for better efficiency during the hectic holiday season, or your business has outgrown your old shipping solutions, you need ShipStation to help you scale your business. Casefile team member Paulina signed up to ShipStation for her Shopify store and was
blown away by how easy it was to automate shipping tasks. With everything managed in one simple dashboard, Paulina can track orders and print shipping labels with just a click. If you're looking to take your e-commerce business to the next level, ShipStation is the tool you need. It's the fastest, most affordable way to ship products to your customers, with discounts up to 89% off UPS, DHL Express and USPS rates. Plus, you can seamlessly integrate with the services and selling channels you already
use, making it easier than ever to manage everything in one place. Scale your e-commerce business with the shipping software that delivers. Switch to ShipStation today. Go to shipstation.com code CASEFILE. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Police went to speak with the physicians treating Sarah Stouty. They had performed multiple tests to identify what was impacting her, but everything medical or genetic was ruled out. Although there was no trace of alcohol, illicit drugs or poisons in Sarah's system,
a doctor remarked that her condition was very suspicious. A nurse had more to add. Sarah was barely clinging to life, but her mother Diane had only visited her a couple of times. Moreover, Diane's behaviour was described as inappropriate. She joked and laughed with hospital staff about her daughter's condition and said that she planned to go on a vacation to Florida soon, regardless of Sarah's status. Police came to learn that Diane had also acted strangely after her husband and son's deaths. According to friends of the Stouties, Diane treated Mark's memorial service like a party. She displayed no outward expressions of grief and seemed more concerned
about being the perfect host and making sure guests were catered to. When a neighbour saw the coroner's van outside the Stouty home after Shaun's death, she rushed over to check on the family. Diane answered the door and the neighbour asked if everything was alright. Diane responded casually, Oh yeah, my son died. Online Diane barely mentioned her husband and son beyond brief obligatory death notices. Within days, she was back to posting positive Bible quotes and silly memes. As detectives began re-examining the deaths of Mark and Sean Stouty,
Diane agreed to be interviewed, unaware that any investigations were taking place. She was first asked about Sarah. Diane explained how a week earlier Sarah had complained of a mild headache and stomach upset which resulted in her vomiting a few times. To Diane, Sarah's illness didn't seem that bad as she had seen worse cases of the flu. Sarah spent most of her time in bed only emerging to vomit into the toilet. She had no appetite but was able to take fluids. Diane said Sarah's usual schedule consisted of her staying up all night with friends and sleeping during the day so she hadn't noticed anything was seriously off until Sunday.
That morning Sarah was bedridden and unable to attend church. The rest of the family went without her. When they returned home at around 12.30pm, Sarah was still in bed, seemingly resting. Hours passed before Diane went to check on her again. By then, Sarah was unresponsive. Diane carried Sarah out to the car and rushed her to the hospital. Despite being a trained nurse, Diane was mystified as to what had caused Sarah's illness. All she could say was that it had done a number on her. When asked if Sarah might have harmed herself, Diane said that was a possibility. Sarah had bipolar disorder like her father and had threatened self-harm in the past.
But Diane asserted that her daughter's behaviour had been fine lately. She'd also checked Sarah's medication and it appeared normal, ruling out the possibility that she had overdosed on it. Diane suggested that Sarah might have, quote, gotten into the cleaners, meaning that she could have intentionally consumed poisonous household cleaning products. Diane was asked to be more specific. She responded with a laugh, what do I have? I can't see her taking soap, yuck. soap, yuck. Diane was then asked what she thought happened to Sarah. She fell silent for a moment before replying with an exasperated sigh, I really don't know, I've been trying to rack my brain to figure out what happened.
I really can't think of anything. I don't know. It just doesn't make sense." Diane was told that further tests would be carried out to establish what exactly happened to Sarah. When asked if she thought anything suspicious might be found, Diane responded, might be found, Diane responded, I have no clue. I don't even know what to look for. I mean, if they're looking for some kind of chemical that she may have taken, I can't think of what it would be. And if the tests did come back confirming the presence of a chemical, how would Diane explain explain that. She shrugged her shoulders and answered, I don't know. Mark and Sean Stouty were both cremated, but Sean was autopsied beforehand. As part of that process, the medical
examiner had taken samples of Sean's tissue, blood, and hair. The samples were stored for a certain amount of time post-mortem, allowing for additional testing to take place if necessary. Although Mark wasn't autopsied, samples of the dried blood around his mouth had been collected and similarly stored. The interviewing detective asked Diane, The interviewing detective asked Diane, Is there any reason that from samples taken that there might be some sort of correlation, some kind of link, something that might be similar between them? Diane gently shook her head and replied, I don't know. The detective pressed on.
And if there was, what would your explanation be? Diane repeated, I don't know. The detective then abruptly asked, What was Mark's life insurance policy like? Diane divulged that Mark's $20,000 life insurance payout had helped pay for a nicer home. Diane intended to use Sean's $15,000 payout for bills. Sarah's policy would net Diane a further $15,000. Her other two daughters' amounts were the same. Diane was asked what she would spend Sarah's life insurance payout on. I have no clue, she replied. By now Diane's mood had shifted. She'd become solemn and contemplative, allowing for long moments of silence before answering questions. When asked if there was anyone that would want to harm her family, Diane claimed that Mark had a lot of weird acquaintances who were into drugs. As for her kids, she said,
I can't imagine anybody trying to harm them. Diane was encouraged to open up about her marriage with Mark. She eventually admitted that it wasn't good, saying that Mark had a binge drinking problem, a cannabis habit, and had been unfaithful to her. Diane could never bring herself to kick him out as she feared he would take his own life. When Mark died, it was actually a relief. I just don't tell people that, Diane admitted, before adding, despite all his faults, I still loved him. I still loved him." Suspecting Diane was holding back information, the interviewing detective appealed to her religious beliefs. Referring to her as a God-fearing woman, he asserted that the right thing to do was to
speak honestly and ask for forgiveness. He told her, I think you're a very good lady with the right intentions. Everybody reaches a tipping point or a breaking point. Maybe certain decisions are made that normally wouldn't be made. Often times the best way to ask for forgiveness is to talk about it and give an explanation. Diane expressed fear of going to jail. She was told to put that thought aside and to just focus on showing remorse and seeking forgiveness. Finally, after two hours of questioning, Diane flatly admitted, To put it really short and sweet, I knew they were drinking antifreeze. Antifreeze is an additive that lowers the freezing point of a water-based liquid. It is used in vehicles to stop the water in the engine cooling system from freezing during winter months. Commonly known
as engine coolant, antifreeze can be purchased at motoring supply shops and gas stations and is a common item found in residential garages. It is extremely hazardous when ingested. It only takes a small amount of antifreeze to poison the human body, with symptoms appearing gradually over several hours. The impacted person can feel or appear inebriated and suffer from headaches, fatigue, lack of coordination, grogginess, slurred speech, nausea, and vomiting. As the body breaks down the antifreeze, the chemical can interfere with kidney, lung, brain and nervous system function, with organ damage occurring 24 to 72 hours after ingestion. It results in rapid breathing, a racing heartbeat and convulsions, concluding with loss of consciousness
and death. Diane Stouty was asked how she knew her family members were drinking antifreeze. She replied, Because I saw them drinking it. I didn't know what else to do. I really didn't. Diane admitted that she had reached a breaking point. She claimed she didn't want to hurt her family, she was just mad. She was tired of working hard to provide for them while they took advantage of her and showed little appreciation. In Diane's words, Mark was a deadbeat who stayed home drinking, smoking and enjoying his music. Diane had grown to hate
her husband and said he lashed out violently at her and their kids. She couldn't stand being with him any longer, so she killed him. She did the same to Sean because she was fed up with caring for him. She described Shawn as more than a bother, more than a pest, who was always interfering in everything she did. Shawn's autism prevented him from holding down a job. Diane felt he was being wilfully disobedient in his inability to contribute to the household. She felt the same towards Sarah. They often argued about how Sarah didn't try hard enough to get a job. Diane killed Sarah because she didn't want to wind up paying off her student loan debt. She felt very differently about her two youngest children, Rachel and Tia. They treated her well and caused no grief, so Diane hadn't poisoned them. She put it bluntly, I'm not a perpetual killer. I'm just stupid. I regret doing it. I really do. I've screwed up everybody. I've screwed up my whole family."
Diane had researched online and learned about the harmful qualities of antifreeze. It was easy to acquire and because of its sweet taste and lack of odour, easy to disguise. No one would suspect Mark, Sean or Sarah had been poisoned with antifreeze unless medical personnel knew to look for it, as its symptoms were similar to many normal ailments. Furthermore, the chemical's raw components were easily missed in an autopsy because they weren't part of normal toxicology screenings and required advanced testing to detect. Diane ordered bottles of antifreeze online and poured a couple of teaspoons into Gatorade for Mark and Coca-Cola for her children. She served the lethal concoction to her unsuspecting victims
over a period of several weeks. The poison took effect within days but often just resulted in mild flu-like symptoms. When Diane's target didn't die quick enough, she increased the dosage of antifreeze until it had its desired effect. Following Diane's shocking confession, detectives arrested her and began seeking more information about the Stoutie family dynamic. Sarah was still in hospital and 11-year-old Tia was traumatised by her family's ongoing suffering. Yet there was still one other sibling who could provide some insight. 22-year-old Rachel Stouty agreed to speak with police. She was unaware that her mother had admitted to poisoning her father, brother and older sister. In contrast to Diane's account, Rachel said that Mark was a nice dad who fostered his children's independence. She admitted that
her parents argued a little bit over money, but no more than any other married couple. Sometimes Diane took issue with Mark's friends as they drank and smoked. Rachel recalled her parents breaking a table during one disagreement, but overall they were close and had a pretty good relationship. She saw no abuse and the only bad things she had to say about her father had come from her mother. As for Shaun, Rachel said he was extremely low maintenance. All he needed was a puzzle or comic book and he was, quote, a happy camper. Sean was independent and content being alone, hardly the imposing pest Diane had made him out to be. Rachel didn't consider him to be a burden at all. He had a good relationship with his siblings, especially Sarah. Rachel said that when Sean
was sick, everyone took turns looking after him, though their mother primarily cared for him during the day while she worked from home. Diane gave him Coca-Cola as it was one of the few things he could stomach. When asked about her mother's reaction to Sean's passing, Rachel said Diane wished they could have done more for him. She felt like a failure as a mum, because it was one thing to lose your husband, but far worse to lose a child. Rachel remembered when Sarah fell ill too. The toilet was right across from her bedroom, and at night she could hear Sarah going in to vomit. Rachel tried to convince Sarah to eat, but she had no appetite. She could manage to drink though, so Rachel and Diane would
bring her fluids. Things eventually deteriorated to the point where Sarah couldn't get up off the floor. When she lost consciousness, Rachel helped carry her out to the car and take her to the hospital. According to Rachel, Diane expressed guilt over Sarah's predicament too, lamenting that she should have taken her to the hospital sooner. Rachel also recalled the time Sarah had threatened to self-harm. It was during middle school and Rachel was certain it was only a cry for help. Since then, Sarah hadn't expressed any suicidal thoughts. She had been a high achiever at college and was otherwise doing well. Rachel admitted that Sarah wasn't trying very hard to find work, though her options were limited.
She had degrees in French and History and her interests lay in teaching or translating French, but there weren't many opportunities in Missouri as most students learnt Spanish. It was normal for Sarah to spend the day on her computer watching videos online instead of helping out around the house. Rachel was more frustrated with Sarah than her mother seemed to be. Although Diane was disappointed by Sarah's lack of effort, she was patient with her. Rachel had never seen them arguing. Diane would bring up Sarah's unemployment during normal conversations, but it was never in a heated way, more so a gentle nudging. more so a gentle nudging. Rachel admitted that she'd found the situation with her father, brother and sister weird. She worried that their terminal condition was hereditary and she would
catch it next. Diane had reassured her, saying that Mark had a heart problem, Sean's death was due to his seizures, and Sarah's illness was out of the blue. Diane led Rachel to believe that she would be fine. After Rachel had revealed all of this, a detective told her kindly, kindly. What has happened is your mum has admitted to killing your dad and your brother and trying to kill your sister with poison. I know it's hard to process and a hard thing to even think about, but she basically spelled it out to us how she did this and the reasons for doing it." Rachel sat in shock as the truth set in. She then began to sob as the detective asked, did you have any suspicions that Mum was doing anything?
Rachel tearfully explained that she knew her mother was frustrated, but she had no idea that she wanted to harm their family. she had no idea that she wanted to harm their family. Meanwhile, a search of the stouty home uncovered evidence pertaining to Diane's crimes, including a bottle of Prestone brand antifreeze engine coolant in the garage. Next to it was a six pack of Coca-Cola. Examination of a laptop revealed that between searches for Christian sheet music and funny cat videos were many others relating to fatal essential oils, poisons used in suicides, herbs that cause stroke, and where to purchase rat poison. The same laptop was used days after Mark Stouty's death to determine lethal doses of over-the-counter
pain relief medication for adults weighing 48kg. This was Sean Stouty's weight. Officers searched a bedroom and noticed a purple notebook sitting on top of a shelf. The word JOURNAL was printed across the the front cover and the pages inside were full of handwritten musings about the day-to-day happenings of the Stouty family. An entry dated Monday June 11, 2011 stood out. It read, Sometimes I wish I could avoid the future and keep looking to the past. It's sad when I realise how my father will pass on in the next two months and how Sean, my brother, will move on shortly after. And yet, it's really helpful. I'm being warned so I have more time to prepare and cope. Also, I get to have Dad's car when he's gone. It'll be tough getting used to the changes, but everything will work out.
Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This is a public service announcement for renters. If you haven't heard of BILT, you're about to thank me. Paying rent through BILT, you're about to thank me. Paying rent through BILT lets you earn points that can go toward flights, hotel stays, fitness classes, and even your next rent payment. Let me break it down for you. There's no cost to join BILT, and as a member you'll earn valuable points on rent and on your everyday spending.
BILT points can be transferred to your favorite hotels and airlines and even the ones you haven't heard of. There are over 500 airlines and 700,000 hotels and properties around the world you can redeem your built points toward. Points can also be redeemed towards a future rent payment and unique experiences that only BUILT members can access. So if you're not earning points on rent, my question is, why not? Start earning points on rent you're already paying by going to joinbuilt.com slash casefile.
That's J-O-I-N-B-I-L-com.com slash case file. Make sure to use our URL so they know we sent you. Joinbuilt.com slash case file to start earning points on your rent payments today. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. On her Facebook page, Diane Stouty once posted the quote, never miss an opportunity to tell your child I love you. Despite this, only one Stouty child received the bulk of her affection. Diane's third oldest, Rachel, was her perfect golden child. Unlike Sean, Sarah and Taya,
22-year-old Rachel was uncomplicated. She didn't face the same struggles as her siblings and was a successful overachiever. She excelled in school, spoke four languages and played multiple musical instruments. She loved maths, chemistry, art and poetry. Diane plastered her Facebook page with praise directed at Rachel, while her other children barely rated a mention. It was clear Rachel was Diane's favourite and the pair shared a remarkably close, best friend type bond. They understood one another and confided in each other. Rachel also confided in her personal diary, a journal with a purple cover that she kept on a shelf in her bedroom.
Mark and Sean were killed nearly a year after the entry Rachel made predicting their deaths, well over the two-month deadline she had anticipated. Yet the fact she even knew about them beforehand was surprising. And a search of Rachel's purse uncovered a poem she had written after Sarah was hospitalised. It read, Once upon a time there were six and now there are only three. Only the quiet ones are left. My mum, my little sister, and me. In Diane's police interview, she had insisted that no one else knew what she'd done. During Rachel's interview, she was asked directly if she had any involvement in her mother's scheme. you, she was asked directly if she had any involvement in her mother's scheme. Rachel had shook her head no and cried. Following the discovery of Rachel's diary, police conducted
another interview with her. They kept word of the find to themselves and instead just asked how she felt about what her mother had done. Rachel said she was confused and shocked, explaining, "...no one expects to have somebody that they know do that. I mean, who judges who can live?" Detectives then asked, "...did your mother ever say anything to you about any of your family members being in bad health and that they were going to die in the near future? Rachel said that her mother had spoken about Mark smoking and drinking. She said if he kept it up then he wasn't going to make it to the age of 80. Rachel claimed that Diane had never mentioned anything about Sean or Sarah's future. that Diane had never mentioned anything about Sean or Sarah's future. Rachel was shown a banal entry from the Purple Journal found in the Stouty home. She confirmed the diary was hers and that
she had written the entries within. She was then shown the entry where she predicted Mark and Sean's deaths. Rachel thought for a moment before explaining that she had a dream around that time that Mark and Sean would die. She claimed she told her mother about the dream. What did you tell your mother? the police asked. Rachel started to sob tearlessly as she replied. That it would be quick and easy, that they'd be in heaven soon and we could move on. Rachel continued to open up, stating matter-of-factly, I didn't know when my mother bought the antifreeze, but I knew she'd been doctoring drinks with that. Although the interviewing detective was stunned by Rachel's admission,
he remained cool and kept asking questions. Rachel admitted that her mother had confided in her about her intention to kill the others. She offered more insight as to how the plan came to fruition. After Diane settled on antifreeze as her murder weapon, she purchased it online. This was because antifreeze sold in stores has an added bittering agent to prevent accidental ingestion. Diane kept a small amount of antifreeze hidden in a container under the kitchen sink. She would tip out two inches or so of whatever drink she'd poured for Mark, Sean or Sarah and then refill it with the poison. By this point in Rachel's interview she'd admitted to knowing that her mother was intending to kill family members, but maintained that she'd acted alone. Yet,
when explaining how Diane researched by reading a book about poisonous plants, Rachel initially said we would, before quickly correcting her answer to she would. Detectives suspected they weren't getting the full story. They told Rachel that they'd seized the laptop she and Diane shared and asked what they'd find on it. Rachel admitted that she had once searched… how to kill someone. The interviewing detective then asked a risky question, not expecting to receive the answer he was looking for. Your mother would pour some of the drink out and then she would put the antifreeze in the drink and then give it to your father. How
often did you do that? After thinking for a moment, Rachel replied coolly, Once. The detective was stunned. When he pressed Rachel to be honest, she clarified her answer. Three, four times. This gradual drip feed of information formed the basis of Rachel's confession. She would initially give a broad, uncertain or deceptive answer before being grilled with follow-up questions. Eventually, she gave detailed, consistent answers that aligned with the facts of the case. She was first interrogated about her father's death. It was a trade-off, Rachel said casually. Mum would do it, then I would. Rachel mixed the drinks for her father twice a day, once in the morning and once in the evening, for several weeks. She didn't have a clear schedule with her mother, who typically administered her
poisonings in the afternoon, so they often overlapped and served many poisoned drinks to Mark a day. As Rachel's story unraveled, it was clear she'd participated in the poisonings more than just the three or four times she had initially admitted to. Mark didn't fall sick at first. Diane reassured Rachel, telling her, it will take time. It was several weeks before Mark finally became ill. The women continued to poison him with higher doses. By the end, Mark's drinks consisted of half soda or Gatorade and half antifreeze. Diane and Rachel went through upwards of five bottles of antifreeze in their efforts to
kill him. Despite having previously praised her father, Rachel now claimed that Mark was killed because he was turbulent and abusive. This was at odds with her own diary where Rachel had written that her father would, quote, rather cut off his own arm than hurt us. Nevertheless, she went on to write that her father was still more of a hindrance alive. Rachel said she mixed a drink a day for Shaun and one every so often for Sarah, but mostly used bottles of Coca-Cola or Gatorade that Diane had pre-mixed in advance.
Wen asked, why did you guys want to kill them? Rachel replied indifferently, Shaun, I accepted that Mum wanted him gone, but I really didn't think he was necessary. After further pressing, Rachel admitted that she found Shaun annoying. As for Sarah, Rachel said, I really actually wasn't aware that Mum was getting Sarah. I knew about Shaun, I knew about Dad, but I didn't know she was going to go ahead with Sarah." As usual, Rachel's lies didn't hold up under further scrutiny. She soon admitted that she had known about the plan to kill Sarah a month beforehand. As to why they wanted Sarah dead, Rachel explained, other than the fact that she basically lived in the back bedroom and didn't have any gumption to get a job, I'm not certain. Mum probably has her own issues with her. The detective asked,
The detective asked, what about you? Rachel took a deep breath before replying, she's annoying yes, but I don't know. Rachel eventually admitted that she found Sarah very nosy and they fought all the time. She added bluntly, back in middle school Sarah would touch me. I mean, she grew out of it later when she got on the medicine, but she still argues. She still has really inappropriate jokes. She really had no purpose." Rachel clarified that the touching she was referring to was both physical and sexual, but Sarah acted like she couldn't remember it. Despite the seriousness of these allegations and the fact that Rachel was implying deep prolonged trauma had motivated her to kill Sarah, she never referred to it again.
Investigators thought it was convenient that Rachel said Sarah had no recollection of it either. As Rachel was a proven liar, they believed she'd made up the shocking accusation to make Sarah's murder appear understandable. It still didn't provide any justification as to why she'd participated in killing Mark and Sean beforehand. Rachel made yet another revelation. She claimed Sarah was in on the murder plot too. Police were incredulous. If Sarah was aware of and involved in the plan to poison Mark and Shaun, then she would know not to accept any drinks herself, especially once she started developing symptoms. Rachel said that when Sarah fell ill she asked them, am I going to die or will I die soon? Rachel and Diane would reply, I don't know. Sarah didn't ask or accuse them of poisoning her despite allegedly knowing that they had done it twice before.
Nor did she reach out to anyone else or seek help on her own volition. In Rachel's own words, Sarah was very afraid of death and often talked about not wanting to die. Detectives felt that these actions didn't align with the narrative that Sarah knew what her mother and sister were up to. Then there was the question as to why Diane and Rachel had taken Sarah to the hospital for treatment. Rachel revealed this wasn't done due to any sense of care, compassion or a desire to save Sarah's life. It was Rachel's idea because she, quote, didn't want another one to die in the house, cause houses are nasty after somebody's died in it. After Shaun died, Rachel moved into his room
and was plagued by nightmares. She said it was awful that she kept sensing a ghostly presence in the space and she didn't want to experience that again when Sarah passed. Rachel's fear seemed genuine. She was uncharacteristically nervous and shaky when discussing the haunting in Sean's room. She had also written about it in her diary immediately following Sean's death. Quote, Yet I feel your gaze lingering over me. I close my eyes and try not to think of the ghosts of copper and bleach. On my tongue, I try not to think of shuddery breaths or how easily a soul evaporates, leaving nothing behind but a hollow husk curled up on the floor, eyes vacant and dull, arms extended. But what were you reaching for?
What were you reaching for?" As for the youngest stouty child, Tia, Rachel admitted that she and Diane had planned to kill her after Sarah. The motive was similar to Sean. Tia's learning disabilities were a burden and they didn't want to look after her. Rachel remarked, after her. Rachel remarked, I know there's no way in hell I'd be able to take care of Tia. I can't take care of me, so how could I ever take care of her? Following Rachel's harrowing confession, police re-interviewed Diane. Upon learning that her daughter had confessed, Diane made full admissions that she and Rachel had planned, researched, and committed the crimes together. Neither woman expressed a genuine remorse or regret. Nor did Diane show any hint of sadness for sacrificing Rachel's promising future in
favour of grooming her to be her partner in crime. By the time Diane and Rachel's deadly plot was exposed, Sarah Stouty's condition had changed dramatically. Although hospital staff had given her a 0% chance of survival when she was first admitted. In a miraculous turn of events, she was slowly recovering. Both Diane and Rachel were surprised to learn of Sarah's survival, though not relieved. Rachel had even nodded her head and said yes when asked if she still wanted Sarah to die. But Sarah's ordeal wasn't over. The strokes and seizures she'd endured left her with severe neurological damage. She had to relearn to walk and talk. When Sarah was well enough, she agreed to a police interview. She hadn't yet been informed that her mother and sister had confessed to poisoning her.
Investigators wanted to get to the bottom of Rachel's claim that Sarah had known about their crimes. Sarah was told that police had been investigating why she had fallen sick. been investigating why she had fallen sick. What do you think we found out, detectives asked. Sarah replied, I don't know. When asked if she thought anyone would try to hurt her, Sarah said, no, all I know is that I got sick. Sarah was then informed that her mother and sister had admitted to making her unwell. Sarah went on to recount an experience she'd had after Mark and Sean died. One day, she found her mother's personal diary. Sarah opened it and found an entry Diane had written about Mark and Sean's deaths. To Sarah's shock,
the entry also referred to her own death. Unnerved, Sarah confronted her mother, but her concerns were dismissed and she was warned not to go looking in the diary again. Sarah said this hadn't alerted her to the fact that her mother or sister were responsible for making Mark, Sean, or herself sick. Sarah flat out denied being involved in any part of the scheme, and nothing that was uncovered suggested she'd known what was going on. Detectives believed Sarah, but in any case, her brain had been seriously damaged by the antifreeze. It was obvious from their conversations that her mind was foggy and she didn't fully
comprehend what was being asked. Given Sarah's condition and the lack of evidence pertaining to her guilt, detectives ended these inquiries with the belief that she was an innocent victim. Diane Stouty was ultimately charged with two counts of first degree murder for Mark and Sean, as well as one count of first degree assault and one of armed criminal action for the crimes against Sarah. Rachel Stouty was charged with the same offences. In May 2015, three years after the poisonings began, Rachel pleaded guilty as part of a deal. In exchange for testifying against her mother at trial, Rachel would be eligible for parole one day. at trial, Rachel would be eligible for parole one day. At her sentencing, Rachel read an apology she had penned to her sister Sarah. In it, she claimed she was haunted by the reality of loss and grieved
knowing that her guilt wasn't a passing phase. Quote, your suffering could have been prevented and I hate myself for not being there for you. Things will never be the same, but I can try to change to become a better person. I want you to know that you are an inspiration to me. Thank you for showing me what I can be. Rachel Stouty, who was now 25 years old, was sentenced to life in prison with the possibility of parole in 42 years. In January 2016, Diane Stouty also accepted a plea deal. She agreed to plead guilty to all but the armed criminal action charge in order to avoid potentially receiving the death penalty if the case went to trial.
She was subsequently sentenced to life in prison without parole. Since her incarceration, Diane has changed her story yet again. In a 2022 interview with ABC's 2020, Diane claimed that she was completely innocent. She said that her husband was associated with dangerous people who'd put out a hit on him. Someone from within that circle was responsible for poisoning him. She even went on to claim that she had been poisoned at one point, though she offered no explanation as to how Sean and Sarah came to be victims as well. A case detective clarified, There is nothing whatsoever to show that anybody was involved in this case other than those mentioned already.
other than those mentioned already. If Rachel Stouty hadn't incriminated herself in her diary, there was a very real possibility that her involvement in the poisonings would have never been uncovered. A clinical and forensic psychologist told A&E that the diary entries were evidence of how much control Diane exerted over Rachel. It had reached the point where Rachel was fully convinced of her mother's scheme, believing it was, quote, just the way it has to be. Therefore, she journaled about it as if it were any other mundane experience she was dealing with in her life. As a result of Sarah Stouty's permanent neurological damage, she now lives in an assisted care facility and has a state-appointed guardian. Sarah was unable to care for her youngest sibling Tia, who was consequently placed in foster care. In a statement read aloud in court, Sarah said, I prefer to be a survivor than a victim. She intends to fulfil her dream of travelling to France
and becoming a translator. In the meantime, Sarah campaigns to raise awareness of antifreeze poisoning. Following Sarah's ordeal, she struggled the most with how much she missed her father and brother. She lives her life believing their spirits protect her. Quote, Mark and Sean are like angels watching over me, and every once in a while I have dreams that they visit me.
Although Sarah was angry when she found out her mother and sister had poisoned her, she has since moved past this feeling. I forgive them for what they did, because forgiveness is the right thing to do. I can hear explosions, I didn't know what was happening. I'm Vicki Petratus. And I'm Emily Webb. We are true crime authors and podcasters with a long history of interviewing people who've experienced unthinkable events. The next guy had this Molotov cocktail in his hand and I just saw him lighting it. Are you listening? Pay attention.
We're at Link Cafe. A gentleman has taken us hostage. He's got a gun and he's got a bomb. He turned towards me and he had this demonic look on his face and just came at me. These stories will have you on the edge of your seats. My shield man wasn't there anymore. It was me by myself. I had no protection. We are going to die now. Who could get out of that situation? I could hear explosions. I didn't know now. Who could get out of that situation?
I could hear explosions, I didn't know what was happening. It's just a matter of self-preservation, get myself out of there. We get to ask questions that most would never ask. And because of that, we get told things most would never hear about. And I couldn't get my gun out, I'm sort of fighting with him, he's stabbing me.
Maybe he just hit his head on the ground when he went down, maybe he's okay. I saw that she wasn't in a very good way. Yeah, this will be difficult for me to talk about. What draws us to these stories is the strength of the people coming out the other side of what they've been through. But it was eight years before I processed what happened in the siege. There is a way. It's not going to be easy. You might have pitfalls, but you've got to keep going. I'm not going to let it beat me or defy me. So even though these are stories of the unthinkable, they are also stories of hope.
You've got to be the best for you first before you can be the best for someone else. The Unthinkable is available now. Be sure to download and follow The Unthinkable wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.